alright so we're checking out the
pip-boy demo edition this is like what
it would look like if you're in stats
status I guess you can't go into special
or perks yes you can that's a lie there
you go there's your strength perception
endurance charisma look you can look at
some of the perks these are the perks
these are just some of the demo ones
animal friend big league it's like more
melee pickpocket you can look at your
fake inventory I got a bit ten
millimeter pistol frag ones
these are musket cocktail this is the
demo right this is demo mode yes and
when you can you look at apparel it's
like I got a leather right arm you got a
mining helmet and a wedding ring there
vault 111 jumpsuit look at your aid I
have no aid right now because I guess we
haven't found anything yet
miscellaneous we got an atomic command
get some bobby pins - you know locksmith
with that's five Galaxy s5 s6 didn't fit
a new phone you're kind of [ __ ] out of
luck we only found this on the Google
Play Store yes not yet the Iowa I
couldn't even search for it though we
had to get a link on our PC searching
for it on the phone it wasn't there yet
or something
obviously it's coming to both iOS and
Android
you know the game's not out yet so this
is all we got right now demo mode you've
got some shotgun stuff you got your
general data do combat quests yes we
don't have any question for acting I can
click it I go crafting work shops no
workshops no quests look at the map
wanna check out oh look at that map
yet some borders looks like a scroll
around that looks relatively big yeah
the radio which you know pathetically we
listen in classical music if you wanted
to you know like there you go
great this is what I would do I would
have this on my arm
apparently I apparently if you have
small arms like me it's not like look
it's just you know you don't work out
bro I don't get swole like my boss tired
you don't get swole sure Mike my heart
is getting swole behind you there you go